pain travail liberté une quarantaine
d'afghans ont manifesté contre les
restrictions que leur impose le régime
taliban bien consciente des risques
encourus ce matin elles ont défilé
devant le ministère de l'éducation pour
réclamer justice et la fin de
l'ignorance sur leurs banderoles des
références aux 15 ou qu'elle qualifie de
jour noir c'est la date de la reconquête
de kaboul par les talibans après le
retrait précipité des forces
occidentales l'an dernier la réponse des
talibans ne se fait pas attendre
à peine cinq minutes après le début de
la marche un groupe de combattants les
disperse en tirant dans les airs
en un an le gouvernement islamiste a
progressivement sapé les libertés que
les femmes avaient acquise ces vingt
dernières années la dernière restriction
remonte au mois de mai depuis les femmes
doivent obligatoirement porter le voile
intégral en public la burqa de
préférence
éducation travail code vestimentaire
nous faisons face à tellement de défis
que je ne sais pas par lequel commencer
dit cette adolescente de 16 ans
en un an les femmes ont perdu le droit
de fréquenter l'école secondaire elles
sont exclues de la plupart des emplois
publics et souvent les premières
licenciées dans le secteur privé
combien de temps devant nous souffrir
ainsi cette ancienne policière combien
de temps les femmes doivent-elles rester
assise chez elle nous mourrons de cette
situation
privé de l'aide internationale qui
portait le pays à bout de bras
l'afghanistan fait face à une grave
crise humanitaire selon l'onu plus d'un
afghan sur deux vit dans une situation
d'insécurité alimentaire et plus de la
moitié des enfants de moins de cinq ans
souffrent de malnutrition aiguë
c'est aussi la dure réalité contre
laquelle se battront coûte que coûte des
groupes de résistance courageuse jusqu'à
ce que leur dernier cri soit entendue
ici louis-philippe trop tôt radio canada
montréal